[Music]
there's a local furniture superstore
ready to help you create your dream
living space let's head to instyle
furniture
hi i'm glenn cordero and you're here at
install furniture where you can have it
your style your way it's a furniture
superstore for your dream home
[Music]
here at install furniture we have over
80 000 square feet of furniture options
that's everything from dining room
furniture living room bedroom children's
furniture
outdoor furniture
we even have accessories and lighting
options they do everything from
traditional to contemporary and have all
the fabrics and materials you need to
make your house a home when you first
visit in style furniture you can expect
our friendly sales staff to guide you
and help you with whatever it is you're
looking for for your specific tastes
hello welcome to instyle might as well
put that friendly staff to the test
right let's go on a mission to find a
new accent chair any specific color
scheme you're looking for i just want to
pop a color maybe a little pattern
i have a few right here
these are some pattern accent chairs
this is great a lot of people a lot of
people like that one because it's like
it's very comfy and fluffy and fuzzy
well that was quick after you find what
you're looking for in style makes it
easy for you to take home the furniture
you want the day of
we offer same-day delivery
free delivery free setup we have a lot
of financing options
with a few zero down options as well we
just make the whole process really easy
and with new furniture for your home
comes new artwork for your walls of
course the artwork really does
catch a lot of people's eyes and you
have a lot of variety in terms of topic
color scheme
at the animals i see
you know plants and flowers i see
aaliyah
you have something for everybody right
yeah
exactly exactly because different
different people's homes reflect
different tastes and you won't have to
worry about this furniture superstore
having low inventory for all your black
friday holiday and dream home shopping
we're located at 2189 west craig road
unit 101 at the intersection of craig
and clayton we're open seven days a week
monday through saturday from 10 a.m to 7
p.m and sundays from 11 a.m to 6 p.m
thank you install furniture superstore
for sponsoring this segment they're
located in north las vegas and give them
a call at 702 6369
or visit
instylefurnitureinc.com remember their
special offer exclusive financing
specials with zero down payment options
available and free delivery on most
purchases